[Music]
stern is trying to go big I'm ticked up
[Music]
chasing millennial get to the bottom of
the world's hot you're not gonna be
famous if you don't do this
what's a tick-tock me what's a banger
what's passed tank fyp
try not to have to cringe loot in this
installment of a colonial tried to make
a viral tick-tock a banger the reason
I'm doing this is because I want to be
tick tock famous because if you're not
tick tock famous in life what really are
you old I guess which is what I am a
week ago I set out to make a viral tick
tock and discover the world of tick tock
means but before we get to that tick
tock I wasn't rolling
tick tock is very hard browser don't eat
the ride don't eat draw the wrapper
tick tock is the video sharing app
killing sorry dominating the lives of
every teenager right now it's all about
making watching and sharing 15 to 60
second videos most with music open the
app and you're in the for you feat this
is an endless feed of videos the
algorithm thinks you'll like keep
swiping up and you get more and more and
more and more and more and more and more
videos it's incredibly easy to make your
own video and add music to it that means
so many dancing and lip synching videos
the tick tock is much more than that now
memes are central to tick tock and I
blame them for why I got completely
hooked on the app a meme is really
anything that spreads on the Internet
and that is iterated on or reinterpreted
on tick tock a meme can be a song a
dance a filter even a hashtag that lots
of people start to post but I just had
to find out how do you make a viral tick
tock or what the kids call a just
learning what a banger was wasn't enough
I needed to learn how to make one is the
simple stuff and Omar is more about like
what caption you put the video could be
like trash if your caption isn't good so
with that I set out to make some tic
TOCs on my own by joining a couple of
different means so a thing I think is
very funny on tick tock is people are
making their own shoes and they're
pairing the video with Iggy azalea's
work
walk a mile in these Louboutins
so I'm making airpot heels with the most
advanced tools you could possibly get
all my credibility is going down the
drain right now now I need to set up the
shot of me walking okay hit video hit
record okay okay gonna strut it welcome
feeling really nice with these thinking
about wearing them to the next Apple
event within a few hours of posting it I
had a hundred new followers in 600 views
but a far cry from a banger these look
nice I tried a few other popular memes
while I was at it like where you give
your dog overall egg and another where
you put Mentos and Diet Coke those
didn't exactly take off how are you
supposed to get it in and then close it
I had to try something else
and I'd heard about collabing he just
wants to like it so I went to the pros I
headed a Trenton New Jersey to meet the
splash twins - 17 year olds who have 2.6
million followers on tick tock I'm
Shelly I'm onna I'm Shelly I Lana I'm
Shelly I'm honor how often do you
tick-tock like I'll be in class I'm not
doing anything in class I'll just be in
class my your project the only time we
now on to talk is throwing basketball
practice which is from 2:30 to 4:30 I
mean school - and class we're like if
I'm done my work yeah I strove to
tick-tock so we find ideas for lunch so
you can make videos and lunch you think
we can make a banger you're making
banger here right now today Shelly and
Anna told me that music is core to the
dances they pick
so the the try part so when you put this
leg out this worm goes like that okay
[Music]
they're so supportive and nice let's
keep repeating it I'm so sorry after an
hour I finally had it down I posted it
and thanks to the splash twins is
following I got 500 views in the first
hour or so that's it I hearted it
already that tapered off and it hit
about 1,500 views in the next few days I
also blew my father encounter without
500 it's all one big cycle Amin takes
off you rip on it and post your own you
keep checking the app for those likes
shares and views and then tick-tock
feeds you more means in your poor you
page that you're probably gonna want to
join in on next it's been a week I made
a lot of tic TOCs
I made 0 bangers but I learned a lot
along the way and the biggest thing I
think I've learned is that tick tock
really perpetuates or accelerates the
mean cycle and it hooks you big time
that's it for this installment tune in
next time when you out of Stern learns
about another thing teens are doing
that's the world that's a while eat